la présidente je me lis mes chers
collègues qu'ils soient professionnels
ou volontaires les sapeurs-pompiers
français sont un exemple de dévouement
toujours prêt à affronter tous les
périls pour se couvrir nos concitoyens
pour autant rien ne peut justifier de
les exposer à des menaces mortelles qui
devrait être assez facilement évités en
1999 un sapeur pompier s'est vu arracher
une jambe par l'explosion d'une voiture
de gaz pétrole liquéfié gpl les
enseignements de ce drame ont été tirées
ces véhicules ont été sécurisés grâce à
une soupape permettant une lente
évacuation du gaz
cependant aucune réglementation est
imposé sur les bouteilles de gaz de gaz
classique gpl et propane que l'on trouve
partout en france
pourtant quand elles sont impliquées
dans un incendie ce qui est fréquent
elles sont un facteur terriblement
aggravants en effet elle explose dans un
délai inférieur à 5 minutes lorsqu'elles
sont immergés dans les flammes
il s'en suit une élévation de la
température un violent accroissement de
la pression entraînant des projections
de fragments de tôle en effet missiles à
des distances supérieures à 80 m les
conséquences sur la période 2010-2017
sont effroyables décès d'un
sapeur-pompier professionnel neuf
personnes grièvement blessées
essentiellement sapeurs-pompiers
sinistre avec impossibilité d'attac pour
les soldats du feu et des dégâts
considérables
il paraît donc impératif d'agir au plus
vite
à l'instar de la réglementation des
véhicules gpl c'est de là n'a pris que
deux mois afin d'éviter de nouveaux
drames humains et d'énormes préjudices
matériels heureusement les bouteilles
d'une nouvelle génération ne pose pas de
problème mais il s'agit pour le très
important stock de bouteilles d'acier de
remplacer l'ancien dispositif par un
couple soupapes fusible ce qui pourrait
se faire raisonnablement dans un délai
de 5 à 8 ans de nombreux pays européens
ont décidé de sécuriser leur parc de
bouteilles de gaz sur le type de
dispositif explosé ci-dessus le
royaume-uni l'espagne le portugal
l'allemagne la belgique le luxembourg la
suède la finlande et le danemark
ces états ont pris la mesure de l'enjeu
c'est une évidence la france doit
prendre au plus vite ce chemin pour la
sécurité de la population et
particulièrement celle des sapeurs
pompiers
aussi monsieur le ministre quelles sont
les mesures précises que vous envisagez
sur ce sujet et dans quel délai la
parole est à monsieur olive
et du soft secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre l'action et des comptes publics
merci à madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur boulot le gouvernement partage
votre souci d'améliorer les conditions
d'intervention des sapeurs pompiers
professionnels et volontaires et de
sécuriser au maximum les conditions
d'intervention de ceux ci dans ce cadre
vous avez bien voulu rappeler sollicité
notre ascension sur le sujet de la
sécurisation du parc français de
bouteilles de gaz et plus
particulièrement sur le danger que
représente l'exposition aux flammes de
ces mêmes bouteilles
certains représentants des
sapeurs-pompiers vous l'avez rappelé
estiment en effet qu'elle devrait être
obligatoirement une munis de soupape
c'est là un sujet qui est extrêmement
contraint endroits et sur lequel je
souhaite vous apporter les éléments
suivants les bouteilles conforme à la
directive que vous citez sont en libre
circulation dans l'union européenne qui
n'impose pas et n'interdit pas les
soupapes
il ne peut donc y avril ne peut donc pas
y avoir deux sur trois positions pour
ses bouteilles là
néanmoins l'utilisation du parc
historique qui représente aujourd'hui
encore la majorité des bouteilles en
france reste possible
ce parc historique n'est pas équipé de
soupape susceptibles d'avoir un effet
favorable pour l'exposition des sapeurs
pompiers en cas d'incendié
mais elles sont équipées d'un limiteur
de débit incompatible en l'état actuel
des techniques avec la soupape qui
permet de maîtriser le risque lié à des
chutes de la bouteille sur le robinet à
la suite de contacts avec les sapeurs
pompiers le gouvernement a décidé de
confier à l'institut national de
l'environnement industriel et des
risques ineris une étude relative aux
comportements des bouteilles en acier de
gpl soumis à un feu cette étude qui
s'appuiera sur les essais déjà réalisé y
compris par les sapeurs pompiers
eux-mêmes permettra de développer un
modèle théorique de prédiction du
comportement d'une bouteille de gpl en
acier prison un à 9 reprises en un feu
et de déterminer les avantages et
inconvénients des différents dispositifs
de sécurité envisagées dans le cadre de
cette étude il conviendra de mener une
analyse de risque pourtant sur
l'ensemble du cycle de vie de la
bouteille pour ne pas se limiter à la
seule prise en compte du risque du
risque d'exposition au feu par exemple
stockage en extérieur à des températures
plus ou moins élevé par exemple ou
encore en conditions de transport les
résultats de cette étude permettront
d'argumenter une proposition qui visera
à rechercher l'appui d'une majorité des
états membres de l'union pour modifier
si c'est nécessaire et vous semblez le
penser
la réglementation européenne qui couvre
la conception de ces bouteilles de gaz
du parc historique
le ciboulot il vous reste 20 secondes
pour une petite réponse réponse sera
bref je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
et je vous entends mais de grâce de
grâce faisons vite faisons vite et
épargnant les d'autres vie puisqu'on en
a que malheureusement certains
sapeurs-pompiers en pâtit de cette de
cette problématique des preuves des
bouteilles de gaz il faut vraiment
prendre en compte très vite